most of the high performers that I know
about are coming from a place of
insufficiency they're trying to prove
something to that parent that teacher
that bully that group of friends or
whatever from their childhood that they
actually are worthy of Love appraise or
acceptance or admiration sometimes I
feel like success is a fluke imposter
syndrome nobody knows that I'm not
supposed to be here it almost feels like
one day someone's going to come out of
the woodwork and go oh this actually
isn't your life you actually don't
deserve this you're the lonely kid by
yourself
we made a mistake it's not supposed to
be you it's supposed to actually be that
guy over there